breaking news out of Texas and it is
heartbreaking in an active shooter
situation has occurred three young
children and a woman in California
Oklahoma Virginia AR-15 the shooting
another one a teenage girl and a young
woman died we are once again talking
about gun violence in America
[Music]
in Uvalde Texas the seasons have passed
it's seven months since a gunman killed
19 young children and their two teachers
but here time has not healed
well I remember in the hours after the
shooting these streets were packed with
news crews from all around the world
it's quiet now they've gone they've
moved on but
the school is still here it's closed now
it'll be demolished but all those
reminders of such tragedy they are all
around it does make you wonder how a
community like this can ever really
recover
her birthday came went
the holidays have been very difficult
I feel like the world's Moving on but
we're left stagnant
at home with Kimberly and Felix Rubio
I'm introduced to their daughter through
memories just beautiful smile beautiful
girl she really does
Lexi was their little girl their star
I think we'll ever be able to heal from
what has happened
uh people want us to heal but
I think just biting our time until we
get to be with her again one day
that's how I see it
there is a sadness here that will never
recede
one home one loss of so many this
American reality now so often feels
tragically banal
but absorb the stories look at the
numbers the scale is staggering and it's
getting worse
we've taken a two-week snapshot of
America the two weeks around Uvalde the
bigger the dot the greater the number
killed and injured in two weeks over two
thousand shootings more than 800 people
dead over 1700 injured not exceptional
normal
because all over this country strangers
are bound by grief
she loved ice cream
she loved her siblings her parents
she's just a well-rounded little girl
Don was a a bright Soul their words
thread together
they're broken by gun violence breaking
news in Mecosta County where three young
children and a woman were shot and
killed three days after Uvalde 1500
miles north in Michigan another mass
shooting a domestic this time a mother
Dawn Gillard and her three children shot
dead her partner their father charged
with the murders it made the local news
but not much more because here in
America it is unremarkable
in fact so unremarkable that Dawn's own
cousin saw the story but didn't realize
it was about his family I stopped I read
the headline
and I just kept scrolling it didn't have
her name or anything like that it I just
scrolled past it it was a domestic
violence situation leaning on guns in
that way that was
his crutch he leaned on that to
to do what he did the killing of Dawn
and her children represented one of 30
mass shootings Across America over our
two-week snapshot 30 shootings in two
weeks where four or more people were hit
in America a day without a mass shooting
is now rarer than a day with one if that
gun wasn't there
um
maybe don would have been injured the
outcome would have been different
there wouldn't be four
family members dead
was an extremely bubbly personality
I mean full of life
you would know she was always in a room
I mean she had an R about her a joy
to her to her being and uh and she had
aspirations
six days after Uvalde in Philadelphia a
weekend of violence at least 15 separate
shootings a teenage girl and a young
woman died the teenage girl was Andrea
de la Santos hit in the head by a stray
bullet from a gang member's gun at a
party
meeting her parents seven months on is
desperately sad you know I think it was
a Father's Day she wrote me a nice note
she said Dad I know sometimes I give you
a hard time
and you and I are alike I understand
that but I want to tell you how much I
love you and I know how much you care
about me so that that I have that letter
still saved me
it strikes me that you've you've you've
just been forgotten I mean no one's been
caught for
killing your daughter no one is helping
you there is no there is no support
around you I mean it's it's awful I'm so
sorry
yeah well thank you it is awful it is
awful and I would even characterize this
as as inhumane
inhumane
um you know like I said before I mean
nobody knows the shoes we're walking
in
uh until it's happened to you I mean and
and we I would have said this uh
watching the news I mean we were so well
aware before happened to our daughter
and our fear is that you know Andrea's
life will just be
lost and just be another statistic in
Philadelphia or in this country and uh
and that those that did it will just go
on with their lives while they've
shattered ours
two weeks in America
now look at the whole year nearly 20 000
people dead nearly forty thousand
injured families now incomplete broken
Across the Nation
we can we can look at all of them and
determine that there's a common
denominator and it's the gun it's too
easy to get guns teenagers 17 18 19 were
guns it's clear what's going on it's
clear what people are seeing hearing but
some just wanna
block it out America's had enough of
this American people want change we just
have to get it through to our leaders I
would say though if we do bring about
change it's not us this is Lexi we're
just doing this for her
breaking news from deadly mass shootings
massive emergency response at the scene
active shooter situation